mira es una elección muy complicada la
pandemia ha enredado todas las cosas
particularmente el tema del voto por
correo que como dicta la constitución de
este país tiene que ser contados por
entero entonces hasta que no haya un
conteo definitivo de los votos enviar re
correos no se puede cantar victoria si
me preguntan a precios de hoy en este
minuto veo más al presidente de tron con
chance de ganar pero insisto lo que
dicta la constitución es que se cuenten
los votos hasta el final y en ese
proceso estamos en este justo momento
trump ha llamado al fraude ha llamado a
detener el conteo de votos ya hay era
una demanda en la corte suprema sin
tener bases para ello nuevamente no
tienen ninguna autoridad para exigir eso
hay que esperar
todo indica que tres territorios del que
fuera el corazón de la industria
estadounidense a michigan wisconsin y
pensilvania esto en el siglo 20 de
glorioso pasado incierto futuro son los
que volverán a definir estas elecciones
presidenciales está de acuerdo
estudio acuerdo florida fue muy
determinante estaba muy cerrado en las
encuestas las encuestas se equivocaron
de largo en el estado de florida
y nuevamente va a ser como en la
elección del 2016 el llamado club burlar
la el muro azul tradicional de los
demócratas el que va a definir la
elección esta vez este año 2020 y las
fuentes están muy cerradas
estamos esperando violencia tiene que
ver con el llamado del presidente esta
madrugada pasada es una corriente
opinión pública que está corriendo
ahorita y es posible que hay es muy
posible violencia ha estado unido porque
los ánimos están muy caldeados los
márgenes son muy estrechos y la espera
es muy tensa